Al jazeera's undercover reporters want
to launder 1.2 billion dollars of
criminal funds by building a fictitious
Casino Resort overlooking Victoria Falls
what we are going to do is Hotel
Casino
in the gold market yeah the god side of
it that's that's one of the best thing
you can come up with
their pitching to Ambassador Hubert
Angel Zimbabwe's senior Diplomat I'm the
least person anyone would suspect to do
okay
so I can do nothing
Angel says that President Emerson
manangagua owns land for the proposed
development in the town Victor of horse
itself you have a lot of land that is
owned by
of course
you can understand
that then it's easy to dispose of it
just go live let's take this let's put
it this way let's put it this way I
think you understand when I say that uh
so it becomes easy
dirty cash for the project needs to be
smuggled into Zimbabwe undetected
the Ambassador makes a call to the First
Lady auxilia manangagua remember those
people that want to move cash
they would want to know
are we providing the planes or they
provide the place
[Music]
father refers to the president
so I will present it to him then he will
discuss which planes he uses his or they
are on but uh
they discuss flying the cash into
Zimbabwe on the presidential plane
sometimes you'll be busy but we spoke
about it so I'm just gonna present you
today
okay okay I'll do that I'll do that I'll
do that but
um
thank you so much
he says the plan will succeed because it
has the president's approval let me just
say to you what you want to do is
happening all right you have got me the
President right
[Music]
you but Angel first lady auxilia and
president Emerson manangagwa did not
respond to our requests for comment
Alexander James Al Jazeera